on tire garnodier animateurs du comité
des précaires et privés d'emploi cgt est
avec nous sur ce plateau pierre
garnodier bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation directe ur rt france
alors amo pour commencer un sur cette
mobilisation du monde on l'a vu on n'en
pas encore les chiffres officiels mais
près de quatre cent mille personnes à
paris un million trois dans toute la
france selon la cgt en tout cas ce qui a
marqué c'était l'absence de violences on
l'a entendu vous étiez sur place
c'était significatif effectivement de
cette journée un changement d'opérations
chez les forces de l'ordre oui oui je
pense que le dispositif policier était
aussi moins important que lors des
précédentes manifestations j'aimerais
quand même insisté sur la montée en
puissance de cette manif là par rapport
à celle du cese puisqu'on était encore
plus nombreux dans la rue aujourd'hui
que la semaine précédente
donc il ya une montée de la mobilisation
est aujourd'hui le les forces de l'ordre
en tout cas et le gouvernement je pense
est peut-être sorti de la passage du du
pourrissement de la lutte dans
lesquelles ils voulaient nous entraîner
aussi parce qu'il ya eu une série
d'actions médiatiques
de la part des syndicats on voulait
mettre aussi peut-être plus en côte et
le cadre festif
là vous avez passé le lait le thinking
de d'attac avec la chorégraphie voilà je
crois que c'est toujours quelque chose
qui a existé dans les mouvements de
grève et et dans la mobilisation des
travailleurs c'est aussi le côté grèves
joyeuse on essaye de se trouver un temps
dans lequel on puisse prendre la parole
se donnait la parole nous mêmes par la
lutte est du coup donné tout ce qu'on
sait faire montrer en tout cas tout ce
qu'on sait faire
en tous les cas sur le fond ça ne bouge
pas aujourd'hui vous demander le retrait
pur et simple de ce projet de réforme
oui tout à fait parce que bon la
ministre madame bizin essaye de deux
mètres des des corporations les unes
contre les autres des travailleurs les
uns contre les autres
mais si cette réforme là elle n'est pas
du tout équitable on nous a dit que
c'était la réforme de l'équité parce
qu'on allait supprimer les régimes
spéciaux
donc en quelque sorte que les
travailleurs qui était le moins bien
lotis seraient mieux lotis moi j'ai
parlé pour qui ce concerne des
travailleurs privés d'emploi et
précaires
l'indemnisation nos retraites ne seront
plus calculées à partir du salaire qu'on
a perdu quand on est au chômage
mme à partir de notre indemnisation le
décret du 26 juillet dont la deuxième
partie va rentrer en application le 1er
avril va entraîner une baisse de 30 à
50% indemnisation chômage donc les
pensions des chômeurs seront calculés à
partir des derniers étaient au chômage
qui vont baisser de 30 à 50% alors
faudrait que la ministre et nous
explique en quoi ça c'est équitable
alors justement où aujourd'hui notamment
pour ces personnes qui sont sans emploi
ou chômage est ce que vous espérez
encore des négociations
une démonstration comme aujourd'hui est
ce qu elle ouvrir la porte à de
nouvelles négociations selon vous en
tout cas la cgt on a on a combattu le
projet de réforme du gouvernement sur
plusieurs aspects en mettant aussi en
avant la question du chômage des
travailleurs qui sont âgés de 60 par
exemple à 64 ans le chômage des seniors
pour faire une comparaison avec la
réforme de 2010 qui a on à reculer l'âge
de départ légal à la retraite de 60 à 62
ans
il faut savoir qu'il ya eu une explosion
de la pauvreté dans cette catégorie de
la population la 250 7 % d'augmentation
des chômeurs qui sont le rsa donc des
travailleurs âgés de 60 et 64 ans et une
augmentation de des travailleurs en fin
de droit donc on as s 2 75%
donc aujourd'hui le gouvernement fou qui
revoit sa copie parce que la seul
intérêt que cette réforme c'est un
appauvrissement général des travailleurs
et ce à la cgt aujourd'hui on ne
condamne t on de combat ils sont ils
vont aussi pour ces personnes sans
emploi d'avoir été oubliés dans ce
projet de réforme oblige et oublié puis
même totalement décrié parce que vous
savez là si j'étais on a réalisé
récemment la une étude sur les offres
illégales les vins et inventait 20 et 21
janvier dernier est de notre étude il
ressort que 47% des offres d'emploi de
pôle emploi sont illégales mensongères
et frauduleuses et c'est une bataille
des idées aujourd'hui qu'il faut mener
il ya des chiffres qui sont sortis les
offres non pourvues en france c'est 150
mille offres qui sont non pourvus parmi
ces offres pour non pourvus la 87 % ont
été retirés par le patron lui-même donc
sur les 15000 emplois qui restent 47%
sont illégales et 13% n'existe même pas
donc aujourd'hui à à dire qui est
responsable du chômage ceux qui sont
responsables du chômage se sait le
patronat c'est le gouvernement qui casse
les services public et qui casse
l'industrie et donc que ça soit sur la
question des retraites que ça soit sur
la question de l'assurance chômage
il faut arrêter de nous dire que notre
protection sociale et coûte cher
ce sont des droits et ce sont des droits
parce qu'on est privé d'emploi ce sont
des droits parce qu'on a travaillé
pendant toute une carrière et
droit là pour la cgt la casse sociale ne
se négociera pas nous nous la
combattrons et nous la combattrons tout
le temps alors dans le cortège cet après
midi un autre sujet aussi qu'ils étaient
débattues ces sont les derniers propos
du chef de l'état on en parle est je le
rappelle il a alerté sur ce qui laisse
entendre que nous sommes en dictature
comment est ce que vous avez compris les
propos d' emmanuel macron écouter en
tout cas en france
il y avait une forme de démocratie
sociale est cette démocratie sociale l'a
aimée schéma qu'on peut pas le nier
parce que c'est lui qu'il l'a détruite
déjà avec ses ordonnances macron en
cassant les instances représentatives du
personnel non confusion dans les sachets
s'était laissé eux dans une seule
instance qui sont les c s
c'est lui qui a battu cette démocratie
sociale là dans les entreprises c'est
lui qui a cassé la hiérarchie des normes
tout cas qu'il a inversé en faisant des
accords d'entreprise les accords
d'entreprise par mon prévalent sur les
conventions de branches et sur le code
du travail
c'est lui qui a cassé la gueule
démocratie sociale en ce qui concerne
l'assurance chômage et l'assurance
retraite il ya une volonté de l'est de
l'état d'étatiser c'est ce qui
auparavant prévalait du droit privé la
sécurité sociale
elle appartient aux travailleurs elle
n'appartient pas à l'état mais manuel
macron ce qu'il veut c'est étatisée
l'unedic et l'assurance retraite
pourquoi pour pouvoir ensuite mieux la
donne et la livrer aux assureurs privés
s'est livré 417 milliards d'euros de
notre salaire aux assureurs privés
alors écoutez ça c'est une forme de
dictature oui c'est évident c'est une
forme de dictature
c'est ce que la cgtm condamne il faut
respecter la démocratie sociale parce
que c'est avec la démocratie sociale que
les travailleurs auront des droits
sociaux merci pierre garneau dit d'avoir
accepté notre invitation direction rt
frange rappelle que vous êtes animateur
du comité des précaires et privés
d'emploi cgt merci